- So this may sound weird
but I promise it'll start
to make sense eventually.
So I sort of observed the other day
that there are two different
ways that people watch movies.
The first group of people,
they get home from work,
they're pretty tired so
they sit on the couch.
They have a Netflix subscription,
so they throw a movie on.
Doesn't really matter what it is
as long as it's sort of stimulating.
There'll be on their phone,
there'll be eating something,
and they're just, sort of,
they have the movie on.
It's just there for them.
Group number two operates
completely differently.
When they watch a movie
it's a lot more intentional.
Maybe they looked up some reviews on IMDB,
or maybe they heard from a friend
that was supposed to be really good.
So they make a night out of it.
They invite some friends over
or they just watch it
themselves with headphones in.
But they're actively
engaged the whole time.
I call this active movie watching.
Now, being the film nerd that I am,
I fall into group number two.
I very rarely just put on a movie
for the sake of putting on a movie.
I really like film and
I'm really engaged in it.
And I like the formalistic quality of it.
Now, as snobbish as this makes me sound,
the point of this video,
isn't to flex on you
about how cultured I am,
but to explain a point.
The difference between passive engagement
and active engagement,
and how getting them wrong
can actually really damage
your entire lifestyle,
your relationships with others,
and your work and everything.
Basically, your whole life can be ruined
if you don't get this right.
Being actively engaged with something
increases the quality of the
thing that you're engaged with.
Whether it's your work, a conversation,
active engagement is better
almost every single time.
But there's a problem.
Active engagement requires willpower
and willpower is a finite resource.
So it's difficult, if not impossible,
to be actively engaged
with every single thing
throughout the entire day,
all day, every single day.
You're gonna completely burnout.
A great example of this is
we all know a guy like Tom.
Tom spends a lot of time at work.
He's doing really well in his career,
and he's actively engaged
with the problems at work.
Work problems.
That's what problems at work are called.
He's trying hard. He's
climbing the ladder.
But he also has a family,
and by the time he gets home
he's so burnt out from work
that he sits on the couch,
passively watching some TV,
cracks open a beer.
You know, maybe his
wife wants to talk about
some problems that
she's having in her life
and he doesn't really, you know,
he's not really listening at all,
or trying to offer any sort of help.
Maybe his son comes up to him and says,
"Dad, can we play outside?
Can we throw the Frisbee?"
And he's, you know, "Not today son."
And sometimes you do need a day like this.
Maybe you can't be super
engaged with your family
every time you get home from work.
But for a lot of people like
Tom, this is every single day
and compounded over
weeks, months, and years,
this can really put a strain
on the relationships in your life.
So perhaps you can relate to
Tom in your own kind of way.
Maybe you're spending a lot of energy
on things that you
don't really care about,
things that you don't enjoy,
and things that you find
ultimately unfulfilling,
which leaves you with next to no energy
for the things that are
actually important in your life.
So what's the solution?
Do you just quit your job
and sit in your house
in a meditative state,
waiting for your wife
and kids to come home?
The solution is to become better
at mental energy management
or MEM.
So here are just a couple of ways
to better manage your mental energy.
Number one is to take a
survey of your typical day.
What do you do at work?
What are your tasks at work?
What do you do when you get home?
And then figure out how much attention
each of those things really needs?
So obviously, there are things at work
that actually do require
your full attention.
Especially if you have
a job that has a lot
of creative problem-solving.
But most jobs also have areas
which don't require that much energy,
like writing an email or
answering a phone call,
sweeping the floors.
Things that you can really sort of
mentally disengage from.
Write all that stuff down.
Figure out what things are important,
what things you can engage with,
and what things you can disengage with.
But that's sort of the precursor
to the actual tips that I
have, and I have four of them.
So tip number one is to take
more restorative breaks.
One thing that I've noticed is that
when I'm actively engaged
with my most important work,
say I am video editing a very creative,
say it's like a wedding
video or a corporate video,
I pretty much have to be all
there when I'm doing that.
But when I take a break,
I make a critical mistake,
and a lot of the time I just browse Reddit
or I watch YouTube or I
do something like that.
I go on social media on my phone.
And that continues to
work away at my brain.
It's not actually restorative.
I'm still mentally engaged
with whatever's in front of me.
And it's taxing. It's
not actually relaxing.
What I should be doing
is going for a walk,
meditating, taking a nap,
maybe making myself a snack.
All of these things cause you to unplug
and it sort of heals your brain in a way.
Things like browsing Reddit
keeps your mind busy,
and by the end of the day,
you're gonna be so pooped out
all you're gonna wanna do is be a zombie
in front of a TV and breathe air.
So tip number two is to force yourself
to physically and mentally relax
during less important tasks.
Now, this one sounds kind of weird
but it actually works really well.
So say you have something like
a menial email that
you're supposed to write
for an unimportant client,
or say you're sweeping
the floors or something,
or making a sandwich,
whatever your job is.
It's the part of the job
that doesn't require a lot of thought.
What you should do is relax
your body when you're doing it.
Relax your body and mind
and sort of ease, float, be free. (laughs)
Now, this may sound like a
little bit of woo-woo crap,
but it's certainly not.
Listen to me. Believe me.
Actually, you don't have to
believe me if you don't want.
But what you can't deny
is that our physiology
and psychology are intimately linked
in ways we can't even
fully comprehend yet.
What affects the body often
affects the mind and vice versa.
When you relax in your seat,
when you are just a little bit more
lackadaisical in your posture,
you can mentally relax as well.
So if you're stressed out writing an email
and you're angry at the client,
and you're really rigid,
that's gonna mentally wear you out so fast
you don't even realize it.
Instead, when you're
doing less important stuff
that doesn't require too
much of your attention,
just take it easy.
Maybe play some spa music.
Get someone lower down in the company
to give you a little foot rub.
And just, you know, be a douche.
It's not that hard of work.
So don't treat it like hard work.
Treat it like a little mini-vacation
before your actual restorative breaks.
Now tip number three is
probably the most important one.
And that is to be more intentional
with how actively engaged you are
with the work that
requires your attention.
So for me, that's video editing.
So when I sit down to
edit, I should be focused.
Like really, really focused.
And I shouldn't break that focus.
Be very, very efficient with my time
so that it can be over with quicker.
And that's the key here.
Being really, really efficient
in the time that you do have
in your most important work
can get it over with quicker
so that you have more time to just relax,
saving mental energy for the things
that are important in your life.
Delegate a parcel of time
that you dedicate fully
to unadulterated productivity.
Screw multitasking.
I'm talking about diving into one thing
with your full attention and
being maximally effective.
If you learn to do that
for like two or three hours
and you enter this deep workspace,
you can get more done than
you ever knew possible.
Not only that, but it's over with quicker.
So the rest of your day can be a breeze.
Now, tip number four. And this
is kind of the obvious one.
But it's barely a tip.
It's more like a reminder.
And that is just to take
care of your health.
Obviously, if you're not
getting enough sleep every night
then you're not gonna
have the mental energy
or willpower to focus on the
important things in your life.
And mental energy
management just won't work.
All right, that's it, guys.
So really take mental
note or a physical note
as to when you're being
more passively engaged
and when you're being
more actively engaged
and figure out if it's congruent
with your actual values.
If you liked this video,
make sure to hit like
because when you hit like
the algorithm blesses me
with, you know, shoving this
video in other people's faces.
So it helps them out, it
helps the video rank better.
And if you're lurking here,
and this is a couple of times
that you've seen my face
and you haven't hit subscribe yet,
hitting subscribe really helps me out.
And especially if you hit that bell icon
so that you're notified
when I release a new video.
It's all helpful. I wanna
do this as a full-time job.
And once that's actually feasible for me
the quality of these videos
is gonna increase so much.
I can't wait for what I'm
able to create for you guys.
I wanna do like long-form
documentaries as well.
I'm almost there.
I can almost do YouTube full time.
Appreciate your guys' support.
Definitely write a comment down below
to let me know what you
want to see in the future,
or you know, be one of
those thousands of people
who comment the fact
that I somehow look like Mark Zuckerberg.
I still don't see it at all.
Bros not even bald.
I'd honestly prefer it
if people started
calling me Jason Statham,
but I don't have the jawline yet.
Yet? That sounds like I'm
working on my jawline.
Orthotropics. Yeah, I'm mewing. (laughs)